ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show take a look at this
i have a hot take i have a hot take i
actually like candy crush
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so controversial to say these if
you say that you like candy corn people
will like walk away so funny i just said
that yesterday and i was like it tastes
like buttery syrup to me like this is
butters worth it melts in your mouth it
has like a little crust on the outside
anyway dude i'm not kidding i wrote out
a tweet that said guys i kind of like
candy corn and i deleted it because i i
backspace sonic so i was like too
controversial cancelled
[Laughter]
like not anymore
not any
please stop that
don't you see my point now that if
chrissy teigen was eating children it
would be the coolest thing about her
like don't you get it now don't you
understand that a lot of this q anon
[ __ ] makes these people look cooler than
they are
like oh yeah she's some like high
priestess of the satanic relig she's
like a dumb
trash [ __ ]
who somehow
figured out a way to get famous
and she's sitting with whitney talking
about candy corn
i mean you know god bless whitney uh
that wendy williams what a what a woof
that was a big disaster
that week and we love whitney but that
week
was a very large disaster
uh whitney subbing in for wendy williams
who's i believe in rehab or something
something like that yeah or and i don't
if she's not in rehab i don't want to
say she's in rehab mental health relief
uh let me double check whatever's going
on with her we wish her well
um and uh
distefano went on there and he had yeah
he had a rough go of it
yeah
it's not an audience for comedy they
don't really want jokes they want wendy
williams which
who is hilarious and you can't
compete with when you win just like the
snl audience they don't really want
comedy they want to hear stuff and they
want to go yeah like they want to like
like energetically agree and they want
it's like a pep rally
it's just like a pep rally
for people that like are not doing good
and feel upset
and got free tickets to a show
and they want to get like you know
pumped up
that's what it is
what is this i want to talk about this
this cool mom who's going to jail
because i hate that i hate when a rat
implicates a cool mom
everybody knows that when you were in
high school you were in this weird in
between between being a child and being
an adult you got to learn how to be an
adult and learning how to be an adult
involves drinking using drugs and having
sex
and a lot of times you need like a safe
environment or sometimes an unsafe
environment to do all of those things
that's where the cool mom
is you know becomes a thing
kathy griffin used to talk about this
like how lindsay lohan's mom dina lohan
was like you know one of the moms that
would like you know do coke with the
kids and stuff you know but you know we
had families like that we had a woman
when i grew up who had like uh you know
a big eye one big eye and sold us all
drugs and
we we loved her because
it's in someone's gotta treat you like
an adult this is my point somebody's
gotta treat you like an adult even when
you are undeserving of being treated
like an adult this woman had the goal
the unmitigated goal to treat children
like adults
kids that
are
raging hormones that need a place to do
drugs and [ __ ] each other
safely in a wealthy suburban home this
woman provided a what a 6 000 square
foot house big yeah a huge house with
many different rooms and alcoves and
places to go
and she created this environment where
where
cool kids or kids that were in the group
were able to go and get really drunk
test their limits find out how much
booze was too much booze
how are you supposed to learn this
before you go to college and you look
like an idiot you have to learn it
in high school you have to learn how
much booze is too much booze what do you
what what drugs uh agree with your
system what drugs don't
you know and what she did was was create
a vibe
truly
and and she threatened a few people
because
cool moms bad ass [ __ ] like this
woman
have to threaten the week
because the weak are would be rats who
ruin it
for everybody and i mean let's get into
this story a little bit because as soon
as i read it i knew that a great
injustice had been done and one of the
things that you know about me is i feel
comedy
is um a way to correct all the
injustices of the world that's the way i
feel i don't think it is funny or should
be funny i think it should be about
injustices and just to discuss trans
people from any angle
pro against confused and you know that
the democrats are new doing they're now
doing the bill the joe manchin and
kristen cinema they're going forward
with the bipartisan infrastructure bill
and they're carving out money so that
dave chappelle does five more specials
all about trans people on and i thought
it was a good compromise i like that
um
quote here glad she's gone los gatos
reals after mom arrested for drunken
teen sex parties shannon o'connor was
known as the cruel the cool but creepy
mom
um
read some of this ben because i read
this i was incensed
and enraged and
i don't really
have an infrastructure to go and try to
help this woman but if i did i really
would so o'connor is now facing 39
criminal charges including 12 felony
counts of child endangerment this is
more than bin laden
this is more
than
osama bin laden would have faced by the
way
all of the people
who've done all of the things
the destroying of people's property
the the burning down of uh small
businesses nobody's like facing anything
this woman is facing 39 criminal charges
12 felony counts of child endangerment
for quote allegedly applying teens with
alcohol getting them drunk to the point
of vomiting and encouraging them to have
sex
you know what that used to be called
being cool
what the [ __ ]
it used to be called being cool
she's not [ __ ] the kids
she's not watching them [ __ ]
she doesn't have a jeffrey epstein-style
surveillance system right right from
what i understand right
she's simply
creating the conditions facilitating
what may happen anyway maybe she's
lighting a fire under a few of their
asses to get it going
and
she's being charged with
i knew parents back in the day
who would buy us alcohol my grandmother
would buy us a bottle of vodka when we
were in senior year
what is going on
here
what are you supposed to do at a high
school party you're supposed to get
drunk
if you're not drinking a high school
party you're planning a school shooting
what is wrong
it's like
the craziest thing i've ever heard this
woman is being treated now she did chase
down one of the girls and threaten her
in the car
but again you have to keep a tight
circle and this is the thing that
i you there was one kid we used to hang
out with his parents if there was a
fight at the party like his mother would
start beating people
and she'd start like there was a kid on
the ground she was kicking them
they have to defend their homestead
because when you decide to be the
parents that allow
um
um debauchery and uh that type of thing
to go on when you allow
parties when you allow
fun when you make room for fun when you
open the door
to a good damn time people will threaten
it outsiders come in they get too drunk
they disrespect you they threaten a rat
and you gotta control
them physically many a time have i seen
fights with like the parents just get
involved because they have to defend
their home
the arrest comes a year after a number
of los gatos high school students
started a quote me too los gatos smooth
can you imagine this
can you imagine this by the way
a high school student started a metoo
los gatos movement complaining about
quote rape culture at the school
and staging a rally on campus
at the time school officials
said they could do little but contact
local police about activities off campus
which they said they did the o'connor
case when apparent complaint o'connor 47
was arrested in idaho
a message left on herself on wednesday
afternoon was not returned she and her
husband tech executive robert amaral
put their 4.7 million home on sale right
to move to idaho with o'connor and her
three sons
she's got three kids a 15 year old
and a 13 year old middle schooler
and i think it was a 15 year old and his
friends that she was but which is a
little young it is a little in the
defense of the people maybe overreacting
15 is a little young
senior year is a little bit more
appropriate but we had some fun junior
year too
but and i guess when you start junior
year you are 15.
okay so she would go on snapchat
and talk to the kids and get them all
uh to come to their house and get boozed
up and [ __ ]
this is what she did
and
people have a problem with this yes
i mean
again
doesn't don't people realize
once sophomore girl goes i'm glad she's
gone it makes me feel safer
she purchased alcohol
of the teenager's choosing how cool is
that
and encourage them to have sex in her
home in a rented beach house in santa
cruz and in a cabin in lake tahoe jesus
christ you kids don't know how good you
have it don't you know that this is
never gonna happen again nobody's ever
gonna buy you the alcohol you want and
say come [ __ ] lake tahoe on my dime
it will never happen again yes this
[ __ ] had some freak [ __ ] going on yes
probably there was something wrong i
don't know i'm not a doctor but just
looking at this if somebody says come
[ __ ] at my beach house in santa cruz and
i'll get you [ __ ] lubed up with the
booze of your choice i'm telling you
right now i know it's offensive and
horrible but wait a few years you're
going to be dying these same puritanical
monster children are going to be in
college with their [ __ ] hanging out
of a window trying to get [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] and dicks i'm not
gendering this but these same kids in a
few years are just going to be they're
going to be dying the [ __ ] in a beach
house in santa cruz now i do understand
the concern
here
uh that the parents i get it because
it's like is she [ __ ] the kid it is
weird because why is she so into it
which is weird i get it i understand
that
but i'm talking really more to the kids
now if you're a parent you're freaked
out about this i totally understand but
to the kids right now you're kind of
being [ __ ] about this truly
so in one case when a girl was so drunk
she passed in and out of consciousness
in a bedroom o'connor brought in a
teenage boy who sexually assaulted her
while the girl cried okay well
now this isn't good
i don't read the whole
article before i do the show
i don't really do the whole thing
i do cliff notes
you know what i mean
i don't go in and
i'm am i a prosecutor
am i a lawyer
do you think i'm a lawyer
so
now this isn't good but this is the
first i'm hearing of this
and the girl says quote why did you
leave me in there with him the girl
later asked o'connor the complaint said
like why like why did you do that
you knew like what he was gonna do with
me first of all too many likes i'm not
saying it deserves sexual assault but
way too many likes
o'connor just laughed
it's unclear whether any of the boys who
are juveniles will face any penalty
some of the teenagers were so drunk they
told authorities that one nearly drowned
in a hot tub and another in a bathtub
but that's funny
now the rape is not but i don't know
here's the thing
um that's one boy suffered a concussion
when he fell off the back of o'connor's
car she'd been driving the boys around
while they were drinking allowed her son
to drive in the school parking lot where
the other boy was hanging on the back
and lost his grip i mean i mean here's
the deal
the [ __ ] like to have fun
again we are we don't i don't i'm not
this is no good about
the sexual assault thing that is not
good i didn't realize that i thought
this was more of just kind of like get
the kids drunk and we drive around the
school parking lot i mean what is the
woman's really psychotic
because she's doing it in the
school i mean it's wild
they moved there specifically
because the sun uh met a girl online
playing a video game and that's why they
moved to the school to encourage him to
like hook up with her and the whole
thing so it's it's very it's very
orchestrated and very weird and planned
something's wrong
we know that
we understand that but is it is it hack
to just have the same take that everyone
else is going to have which is like damn
this woman to hell
i'm trying
now she's accused of a 120 000
embezzlement scheme yeah i'm trying to
help you shannon and you're making it
hard
they make it so hard
you may have noticed his website he's
been using the nickname quote cool mom
correct i appropriated that to describe
shannon o'connor and by the way even the
the [ __ ] people are saying cool mom
the 47 year old los gatos woman accused
of throwing alcohol fueled sex parties
for teenagers and then moved to idaho
where she was accused of doing the same
there
but we were merely using the vernacular
of the kids as the mercury news reported
when the story broke o'connor 47 was
apparently known as the cool mom
since uh the older son was in middle
school and had raised eyebrows amongst
her parents for her chumminess with the
son's friend do you think it comes out
that she was just [ __ ] the kids very
possible yeah
it would have come out already probably
though
we all feel that she's a threat to the
community we experienced right i had you
know we had
uh uh uh uh people in long island that
were fun
that uh parents that would allow us to
drink and use drugs and they would drink
and use drugs with us but they never
incu uh they never really encouraged sex
i think the worst thing that happened
once was
uh somebody i knew had sex with a girl
and the father at the house watched it
like my friend noticed he was just
sitting in a corner watching that was
but that was the worst
that happened
but nobody knew
beforehand that that was gonna happen
quote we are very grateful that the
judge decided this today and didn't
prolong this
and we got to be careful with how to
title this on youtube because they're
going to give us all kinds of problems
yeah we gotta we we we had dinner with
uh some youtubers the other night and uh
it's all in the titles nice people huh
did you enjoy the dinner it was great i
had fun i had a lot of fun i had a lot
of fun it was good to speak to people
in los angeles it really is i i like to
do these little dinner things and see
where people are at i want to see where
people's heads are at
i think it's funny
and here's my thing with cool mom
you know listen as i read on it's more
complex
than i had originally thought
i thought she was just getting people
boozed up and saying you guys can
[ __ ] house but she's leading people
in the room there's people getting
assaulted that's not good
um
she's denied bail
now they're accusing her 120 grand
embezzlement scheme what does that mean
uh so 120 000 in personal charges on
company credit cards belonging to her
former employer that's a lot of booze
for the kids
uh i think i was reading and there's
tons of articles about this i was
reading she like got limos for the kids
and there's there's a lot of stuff
charged i'm going to tell you this
i'm going to tell you this
many of the kids are going to look back
and say that these were the greatest
times of their lives
not all of them but many of them are
going to look back and say these were
the days
um
and
it's sad
uh
but i remember you know we we didn't
nobody in long island uh was a saint who
was uh parenting us letting us have
parties nobody was a saint
but here's what we were able to do
of course we would drink and and vomit
and people would have sex and there
would be fights and whatever
you know the the parents job i would
hang out with the parents i was the one
who hung out with the parents because i
didn't want to have sex with uh the
women and i enjoyed my friends and we
would get drunk but i was always curious
about uh how much money all the parents
had i always thought it was funny right
to i wanted to know how much money the
parents had so i would always talk to
the parents you know
about all kinds of things the changing
neighborhood
um you know
a lot of the things that were going on
because i knew how to get i knew how to
get into their
uh circle of trust that's true you know
i would just sit down in long island in
long island if you want to get into
someone's circle of trust you just sit
down you have a drink you stare at them
you go things feel different
am i wrong
and they will go on for an hour
they'll be like you're not wrong
and here's why
if this wasn't all creepy enough we know
that our connor and her two sons were
found with at least 10 other teenagers
in their idaho home on the day that
o'connor was arrested two weeks ago so
the parties likely continued there with
a different group of teens
so she the cops roll in and she's got 10
kids at the house yes partying
and the whole reason they move there it
says the son met someone while playing
fortnite online and they believe that
o'connor moved with her sons to idaho in
order for her son to pursue a romantic
relationship with this girl
and the mother of the girl said that
o'connor herself would lavish the girl
with gifts including roses a 200 tiffany
necklace and food deliveries
is it wrong to want the best for your
children
better help that's better hlp better hlp
if there's something interfering with
your happiness
or preventing you from achieving your
goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with a licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's better help
sometimes you feel sad you feel mad you
feel bad
you can't talk to your dad
and you say i wanna end it all but you
have a phone and you call
betterhelp.com
you go online and you set up a profile
you join the million people who have
already taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional and if you don't like that
professional you can switch and change
at any time because it's tailor fit to
your needs it's about you
[Music]
if the boss is making you mad the
girlfriend's riding you the dog is
barking a lot
your mother's a nut and you got a big
butt and you sit around all day smoking
pot
you hate everybody you're not an
entrepreneur gary vee let you down
people on youtube made you believe that
things are possible when they are not
everything's stress you may have ms life
is a shitty thing you call better
help
better help help
everybody's gonna treat you with
r-e-s-p-e-c-t
better help tim bill introducers get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
but tim dillon show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com they
are a big supporter of our show and go
and support them and your own mental
health that's betterhelp.com tim d
betterhelp.com tim d
everybody needs a vpn it's just the
reality you don't want the government
snooping you don't want them selling
your information i mean come on every
time you uh connect to an unencrypted
network in cafes hotels airport your
online data is not secure any hacker on
the same network can gain access and
steal your personal data financial
details passwords go into a vpn just
some cheap hardware is needed a smart 12
year old can easily hack you so what you
do is uh go and get the express vpn it
creates an a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers so they can't steal your
sensitive data it would take a hacker
with a super computer over a billion
over a billion years to get past
expressvpn's encryption fire up the app
and click one button to get protected it
works on all devices phones laptops
tablets and more so you can stay secure
on the go i use it i love it ben uses it
he loves it everybody uses it expressvpn
you know what i do i watch uh
netflix from uh kuala lumpur
with the expressvpn and they have a
succession there but it's all about
mangoes
secure your online
[Laughter]
secure your online data today i'm going
to kill myself in this chair where's our
studio you [ __ ]
nothing
secure your
you big failure
big zero ben
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
tim dillon that's expressvpn
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot com tim dillon you can get an extra
three months free expressvpn.com tim
dillon
expressvpn.com tim dillon
these millennials now let's talk about
this article in the uh new york times
i'm thinking of selling my car i don't
want to drive anymore you know you and
ida made a good case that you thought i
was going to kill someone with my car
and i and because i have rage issues and
stuff but i i'd like to drive fast but
uh
i think i'm going to get rid of it
because i don't like driving and i'll
have a car in texas when i'm there but
when i'm in la i kind of don't want a
car and i should start drinking again
even though it's been 12 years if i
don't have a car
is there anything wrong with me
recreationally drinking and using drugs
what if the only thing keeping me sober
was driving oh man
right
would you feel pretty stupid then huh
yeah i would you convinced me to get rid
of my car
but it's it's true i
i
you should drive
because you're like a wage slave
and i'm regal
and a king should never drive he should
be driven that's right but a wage slave
and i want to get you a little box here
for you to punch in and punch out i want
to hear the sound
[Laughter]
by the way the supply chain there's
ports we went to crate and barrel the
other day the people that are still left
in the workforce are losing it this
lovely woman was like she's like there's
there's ships
in the port of los angeles and they have
all of our stuff she goes our stuff is
on those ships
she was coming apart lovely woman helped
us a lot but coming apart and here's the
headline it says a record number of
container ships waiting to enter ports
of los angeles and long beach there's a
shortage of workers and stuff with the
coast guard or the what is it the port
authority i don't know but whatever it
is it's a massive problem where if you
ordered
a [ __ ] ottoman it is sitting on a
ship
a container ship out on the port you
almost want to take a boat out there and
grab it
and then boat back in
but
we're going to talk now about this
article that i read that i thought was
uh the new york times writes a lot of
articles that don't need to be written
um
and this is uh one of them
the 37 year olds are afraid of the 23
year olds who work for them
quote 20-somethings rolling their eyes
at the habits of their elders in a long
is is a long-standing trend but many
employers said there's a new boldness in
the way gen z dictates taste
you know we were talking about this last
night at the little dinner
uh
there's a nihilism the gen z people that
i've spoken to whether it's the tick
tock kids or people that helped us with
things there's a nihilism
to them which is quite productive
and the nihilism is a reflection of
they have seen
so many institutions either lose
credibility or outright fail
in their lifetime so the collapse of
institutional cr credibility which has
been so widespread
has impacted the way they look at the
world and a lot of these kids now are
self-starters they're independent they
are early adapters onto things like
tick-tock they get on there they build
things they don't know what they're
building they don't know why they're
building it
some of them might but i think they
understand that they cannot wait
they cannot wait for any institution to
give them a shot
and i think there's something that's
very positive about that right
i also believe there are many issues
with that generation um
in terms of
uh
the fetishization
of mental health
of sexual politics
of uh many other trends that i don't see
as as uh as positive
as i see the fact that you know
independence
and being a self-starter and uh
uh being somebody who is not reliant on
these archaic systems and structures
that is good but i think some of these
other things uh are a bit
childish
uh but that's okay because i'm on my way
out right i'm 36 i'm heading towards 37.
i'm out and you have to realize this
your late 30s it's uncomfortable to
realize that you're no longer uh
you don't matter and the things you
believe uh don't matter you will you
will hit peak earning i guess in your
30s 40s 50s that seems to be when
if you can
put together some type of career that's
the best years of your career but what
does that mean the best years of your
career and bill burr talks about this
it's like when you have a kid you just
go in a sinkhole for 18 years and you
don't know what's going on then you
stick your head back up and you're like
wait what happened
the same is when you hit like a stride
in your career you're not culturally
you know looking at everything and
taking everything in you're not you
don't have as much time to
do the things that young people do to
kind of steer culture you just don't
you're not tweeting about your favorite
band
when you're 40 i hope not
some people are
but the v i mean people are now with
that that the the rapper who did the
biden the antibiotic
and all of a sudden everybody on
facebook my aunt loves rap now
my aunt loves rap
she spent years talking about how it was
the scourge of the inner cities her
words
now she loves rap
but the vast majority of people aren't
but this article in the new york times
is basically saying that like
millennials the millennial generation is
like a soft generation but they're uh
weirdly conniving emotionally
manipulative uh they all want gold stars
they're kind of despicable
uh they are institutionalists the
millennials
they are people that uh love um
uh getting a pats on the back and
you know ribbons pinned to them from
what i you know and i am a millennial
and i've seen the way millennials
behaved it was the generation that
talked about colleges and getting into
colleges and you got to fill out your
application that
everything was just this you know mad
dash for some type of
uh acceptance it was this this
you know very visceral you could see it
on people's faces
need to be told that they were good
enough and that they did the
quote-unquote
right thing and there it was formulaic
and and the way that we were brought up
was that we were just threatened with
college threatened
if you didn't go to college what will
people think of you and you won't be
able to find any work and you better
live in fear it was a fear-driven
culture um
and that's the millennial culture to me
gen z seems a lot more nihilistic
uh they don't seem to be looking for
approval as much even though as human
beings we all do but those are the main
differences that i've
noticed you know that they they seem to
be black-eyed nihilists as uh the big
lebowski right isn't that the quote
that's right yeah i mean
these people gen z
seem to be a lot more uh independent
um
and they lay things on the table uh a
little bit more than i think millennials
would i think there may be dare i say
less baggage
with some and i again i know highly
productive people from the general i
don't know
people that aren't doing anything but
from this article a lot of it is like
hey you know gen z people telling their
bosses when i'm done with my tasks can i
go
can i leave
and and again is that is some of that
laziness maybe but i think some of it is
like
you know do you know how much wasted
time that millennials wasted in offices
you know going out for hour and a half
long lunches
and going and uh you know how long it
took someone to open a box of keurig
k-cups for the coffee machine and how
much [ __ ] went on that wasn't work
and it became like this weird
environment for people to enjoy being on
my suit and tie and i'm drinking coffee
at the desk and it was this weird
performative life
uh and gen z people are kind of like hey
man let me out of here if i'm done let
me get the [ __ ] out let me leave can i
leave i did what you wanted me to do let
me leave also gen z has no respect for
their bosses
you don't have any respect
for the people that are and now that has
positives and negatives you don't want
to completely not have respect for
people but you should you should never
be completely
uh bowled over
uh or or too impressed with anybody
especially if your job eventually is
going to be to do what they do you know
you should have a
you know
pretty reasonable
assessment of what they do how they do
it better than you and a lot of these
people are noticing that these people
actually don't do anything better than
me they've just sucked off the right
people they've played the corporate game
long enough they have the right [ __ ]
fake superficial
manner about them that has allowed them
to like fail upwards and to send the
corporate ladder so these little
nihilists are coming to the office
refusing to respect these people and one
of them they actually
one of the young people in this article
asked the uh team leader or the boss the
manager to do something they're like can
you do it
and like
managers hate that when they're asked to
do a task
like a lot of these people are just
completely like they're completely
shocked that
they would be
uh asked to do something
also they're a lot more political which
can get annoying because they want you
you know they want your kombucha to you
know make a stand
they want your kombucha
you know to start talking about
controversial political topics they are
much more willing to do that stuff
you know they're calling it the kids
these days effect
they've noticed it's been happening for
a while
each new generation brings something a
little uh different
um
but you know older generations are much
more likely to go hey let's leave
politics out of things
and kids want everything to be political
younger
gen z
people
i don't work in an office and one of the
reasons i don't work in an office i've
i've spent a lot of time in an office
just like i've spent too much time in a
car i've spent too much time in an
office
offices are for the most part not always
but it you you hit
a a wall and it's
it's diminishing returns in an office
and i think gen z is kind of realizing
that the younger kids are realizing like
i could be out doing my own thing
i could be on only fans or i could be on
patreon or i could be on youtube or tick
tock or twitch
i could be on any of these platforms i
could have an e-commerce business i
could make [ __ ] and sell it i could go
out and sell things i could
do any number of jobs that don't require
me
to be here in this office
staring at these people because when
you're in an office you just end up
staring at a lot you know there was a
woman doreen
we used to work with
who started in mortgages has a very
sweet
nice mom
she was like the mom of the office
and she started as like a secretary and
she was just a fun secretary she liked
having a few drinks
she'd always like she was a sweet woman
and probably still is you know a nice
not too far from cool mom probably okay
and
as things
progressed she got into being a loan
officer
she like started to work as in the
but then by the end of it she had to be
fired for like stealing deals
and it was a whole thing
so
what i'm saying is the culture can you
know really do something to you
so you got to watch out
but i mean if this is a hard article to
care about either way
you know here it goes like uh
yes some guy who owns a food business is
like he heard from junior staff asking
if his company would post a black square
in solidarity with uh the blm movement
on instagram
elaine purcell 34
co-founder of the maternity care startup
oola
got a slack message from one of her
youngest workers after the shootings at
atlanta area spots in march asking what
the team could do in solidarity with
asian americans so they are more
politically minded the young people
yeah and then one of the quotes is you
talk to older people and they're like
dude we sell tomato sauce we don't sell
politics
said mr kennedy co-founder plant people
then you have younger people being like
quote these are political tomatoes this
is a this is a political tomato sauce
yeah i mean this is the big divide right
seemingly the millennials one good thing
about the millennials if there are good
things
about the millennial generation
um
is that
uh
maybe they know when to shut up
maybe maybe they do i don't even know
i'm positing that
and the only reason i say that is
because
at the end of this article they all go
on some retreat and they said the gen
z people were much more likely to like
yeah here we go
um
somebody emily fletcher runs zeva
meditation notice at her company retreat
the junior people were the ones who were
most comfortable stretching the bounds
of what's considered professional
conversation this became apparent when
the staff participated in an exercise
she calls the suffy awards sitting
around the campfire and sharing personal
sources of suffering from last year by
the way who's
doing that
the suffie awards sitting around a
campfire and sharing personal stories of
suffering from last year this is a
perfect example of what millennials do
they go we want to hear about all your
suffering and we're going to award you
based on who suffered them all it makes
everything this weird game
everything this weird need
uh to win it's odd
to earn recognition your suffering
should earn you recognition
okay
so she said about gen z quote they
celebrate human emotion instead of
having an outdated framework of what
corporate should be her company culture
has relaxed even more
but you go up there go up for a second
ms fletcher said getting the most
vulnerable by speaking about partners
cheating on them so these kids were
speaking at the selfie awards about
partners cheating on them or about the
loneliness of a solo quarantine this is
maybe where you go just shut up
truly they'll use it against you
they're gonna use it against you
all the things you're admitting to them
at the sophie awards why are you why i
would not go if they're like we're doing
a retreat we're gonna sit around a
campfire it's like this is why i've
never even when i was in sales i wanted
to stay away from corporate america
because when people start saying we're
going to a camp farm like no we're not
we are not doing that
yeah we're gonna sit around and tell
each other no
corporate
uh
friendship building exercises
not for me
truly not for me
and
this is where i kind of draw the line
this is why i could never function in
like a corporate
company
other than spotify
because if spotify
were to hand me money
then i would absolutely go
sit by
a
uh
fire
and talk about
all of my problems
but yeah i mean it's it's interesting to
see what the future uh please what is
this what keeps going on here is xena
what about what i'm not sure
i can check
uh she wanted a pic of your odometer
we're not there tell you to get it
tomorrow christ almighty
[ __ ]
enough
but it's interesting i spoke to
anakashan about this a
lot um about
the kind of millennial narcissism and
the idea that everybody needs to
get a medal unlike me i deserve it i get
nothing i deserve all the medals and i'm
given nothing
growing up cereal is one of the best
parts of being a kid but i had to give
it up because i realized it was full of
sugar and i don't eat sugar
i've never had sugar
so we're all trying to get better eat
better but healthy breakfast don't have
to be boring do you think that healthy
breakfasts have to be boring i don't
think so but you did i used to why
because i hadn't heard of this company
but why did you think that healthy
breakfast had to be boring because i
don't know you do like you
spinach with like a poached egg it's
boring but you know that you could have
meats in there
i guess i could you could have bacon and
sausage that's boring it's boring to
have eggs and bacon or smoked salmon
it's so traditional or ancient grains i
don't know it's boring that's what my
parents why did you think it was boring
when you know if you have an american
cheese omelette with bacon it's [ __ ]
good
if you have a western omelet it's good
why did you think it was boring because
i want a sugary cereal to get my date
that's a different question
you just said
that you believe healthy breakfasts were
boring i'm telling you that breakfast is
the easiest meal to eat healthy because
you can choose an array of meats and
cheeses and veggies to make something
really cool like a frittata and you're
sitting here with a shitty grin
on your face and you refuse to tell me
why you think healthy breakfasts are
boring why are they boring
it's it's boring to be healthy in my
opinion it's boring is that what's
happening or are you lying because of
the ad no i want to be stimulated are
you lying because in the ad it says that
and you're agreeing with the end when i
eat an omelette i want to fall asleep
they deserve so bored they deserve
better than you lying to them i'm not
lying to you
you're lying right now i'm not
because if i brought you
eggs scrambled with american cheese and
chicken sausage and spinach and salsa
and all you would like it
yeah i'd like that so what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you why are you lying
it's still less exciting than a bowl of
sugary cereal
i do like cereal
what are we talking about
magic spoon cereal what is it
it's a zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four net grams
of carbs in each serving only 140
calories a serving it's keto friendly
gluten facebook took the thing down
where i said i was gonna sell the maid
maybe
still no it's grain free soy free and
low carb and you can build your own box
oh do they have flavors like cookies and
cream and maple waffle they do they have
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry cinnamon cookies and cream and
maple waffle
oh and they just recently brought back
two super popular it sounds like it's so
sugary that as soon as i eat it i'm
going to go crazy and kill everyone i
know
no it can just be like it sounds you
know what happens
when i have sugar i i hit people
everyone men women children i don't care
i react violently to sugar
i choked my aunt once up against her
her um her bathroom door just started
choking her like this and i saw her the
veins in her eyes started to bulge which
one which what which aunt many of them
now what about this
this i won't choke them yeah it's like
you it's think of like a guiltless
midnight snack no such thing if you're
eating at midnight you're a slob well if
you're eating out of your window i guess
try to stay an eight-hour window but you
could start eating at four and then have
it what are you even talking about right
now intermittent fasting that has
nothing to do with this
what is this product
magicspoon.com tim dillinger and they're
a big supporter of this show huge
because people want sugar but they can't
have it because they're little fatties
but magic spoon makes it better right it
does so that the people can eat the
sugar it feels like sugar but it's not
yeah if you want to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and try it today i do well
then use the promo code tim dillon at
checkout to save five dollars food.com
grab a bundle of any cereal and try
today be sure should i do it this fast
wouldn't it be good if i did everything
just first of all go to magicspoon.com
to grab a bundle because somebody just
tried today and be sure to use your
promo template check to save five
dollars over your water and magic spoon
is so confident their product is packed
with 100 happiness guarantee so this
this is this is what i could do um
uh that you know when you go very fast
auctioneering ready go up i want to read
it real fast okay just to show people i
can do it
zero grams of sugar 340 grams of protein
in order 400 grams of carbonate serving
only 140 calories is serving it's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and low carb build your own brothers
no but i i can do it hold on
shut up
build your humble available flavors
build your own box available favorites
to build your own very custom bundle or
cocoa fruity frozen peanut butter
blueberry cinnamon cookies and cream and
maple waffle go to magicians.com tim
dillon to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try today and be sure to use the
promo code tipton and check it to save
five dollars of your order
nice
magicspoon.com tim dillon
magicspoon.com
i use this i love simply safe
it was named the best home security
system of 2021 by us news and world
report you can easily customize a system
for your home online in minutes and get
a free custom recommendations from
simply safe we all know the realities of
the world right now and unfortunately
uh people are gonna come in your house
and kill you i mean this is not
this is not uh
rhetoric this is the reality
okay
do you want that i don't want it no so
if you protect your family or pets
yourself
you got to go simply safe it's a
security system
okay
here's what they do
they make sure it's safe inside outdoor
indoor and outdoor cameras
comprehensive sensors all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who send help the instant
you need it
you know who uh turned me on this your
brother oh really because he said this
is one of the best he sells alarms he
recommended this
he did
i i like it because i like to sleep easy
and i don't want people
trying to kill me
and succeeding i know they're going to
try to do it
but i
i would rather them to be stopped
somewhere between they're having the
idea to do it and then doing it
there are no long-term contracts or
commitments it is really easy way to
start feeling a bit more peace of mind
take advantage of simply safes holiday
sale get 40 off your new home security
system by visiting simply safe.com tim
dillon again that's simplysafe.com tim
dillon for 40 off your entire system
hurry this offer ends soon so here's the
facebook [ __ ] now they're changing their
name to meta i'm old enough to remember
when facebook was you know college kids
trying to get laid by the way if
facebook was still functioning like that
we wouldn't need cool mom to be driving
kids around getting them slammed but
because facebook is no longer
functioning as a dating app for children
it is now functioning as a place for
elderly people to scream into the void
to post pictures of their dead dogs to
talk about their knee operations and and
to start you know these long threads
where people are trying to educate each
other on all manner of topics
they and they think the problem with
facebook is misinformation all social
media is misinformation whether it's
russia or your mother-in-law everybody
on facebook is lying
and so you have a whistleblower and this
[ __ ] comes out and facebook is now
changing their name to meta which is
weird because a restaurant long island i
like did that still a good restaurant
facebook fails to moderate harmful
content in developing countries what did
this whistleblower do
why is she
what is the big deal here
basically she's saying that they're
focusing they
they care more about profit than the
safety of their users so they allow
hateful content and hate groups and
people like that to spread tons of
misinformation that gets people but
those are their users
hate groups are your users
if someone's starting a hate group on
your platform they are a user are they
not
quote facebook was aware that maids were
being sold on its platform
internal documents show that facebook
admitted it was quote under enforcing on
confirmed abusive activity when it
failed to take action after filipino
maids complained of being abused and
sold on the platform according to the
associated press quote in our
investigation domestic workers
frequently complained to their
recruitment agencies of being locked up
in their homes starved forced to extend
their contracts indefinitely unpaid and
repeatedly sold to other employers
without their consent one facebook
document read
in response agencies commonly told them
to be more agreeable it's not horrible
advice
so what is it is it facebook's fault
that people are using facebook to buy
and sell maids
yeah and like the january 6 stuff and
should i post a status right now anybody
want a made
i'm gonna post a status and see if it
gets taken down
let's test this right now
i'm gonna do it to see if it actually
works here okay
i'm posting your status right now what's
on your mind
does anyone want a maid
i have one
chained up in my
chained up
in my basement
she will work
you can hit her
and then under it i'm gonna write test
see that
does anyone want a maid i have one
chained up in my basement she will work
you can hit her test
post
let's see what happens okay
i was unaware of this that people were
buying and selling mates is this only in
the philippines
uh yeah so they're really bad at
managing things in other countries
because they can't
speak the language very well so then
there's like hate groups in like india
against like muslims you are determined
to sell a maid aren't you gonna sell a
maid
i mean this is the reality
how many roadblocks do we have to put up
before people realize
that if you were what do you mean the ai
struggles with non-english languages
isn't this a highly sophisticated
artificial intelligence system for like
english yeah they can't understand
filipino apparently not it says they
support 50 languages when in reality
most of those languages get a tiny
fraction of the safety systems that
english gets so they kind of with the
other countries they just kind of let
them run amok
is the status okay did they take it down
it's still up nice see maybe this is a
problem
the wi-fi is not good here
i have five likes
does anyone want a maid i have one
chained up in my basement she will work
you can hit her
see look like myanmar they couldn't
identify hate speech in ethiopian
languages
uh so there was no safeguards for those
countries
well what are they doing that's so bad
i don't care about hate speech i'm more
concerned with the selling and the of
the maids
well yeah that's that's the worst thing
to me don't you think the maids are like
can we stop focusing on the hate speech
i'm in a closet
i'm getting hit with a broom
does doesn't that make more sense yeah
facebook's algorithm mistakenly banned a
hashtag referencing the quote al-aqsa
mosque in jerusalem's old city because
they thought it represented the militant
group al-aqsa martyrs brigade who are we
like we are like them uh an armed
offshoot is a secular fatah party
document show a lot of our fans are in a
hawk some artists brigade
the company later apologized but the
accidental removal of content serves as
a shining example i love that serves as
a shining example for how the social
media giant's algorithms can stifle
political speech due to language
barriers and lack of resources outside
of north america
so this whole thing's about languages
yeah something i smell a rat
i don't agree with this
this can't be about
that you don't understand
what
can i does anyone ever made in filipino
language in telugu or whatever the hell
they speak
i want to beat my maid in filipino
nobody understands what that is
hey my maid's dead anyone got another
one so as long as i write that in
non-english i'm okay
something's wrong but what about the
whistleblower people say she's a creep
because the greenwald made a point a lot
of this seems to be like
okay we take uh the power away from
these tech oligopolies but then who gets
it the government does anyone feel
better with the government
running the show you don't think they're
going to ban you they'll ban you
this is her francis hogan
where's she from
ah let me see here
i know she's in europe right now doing
this whole thing
this woman is a uh
is she like snowden is she gonna have to
leave the country she's from iowa city
is zuckerberg gonna have her whacked
i mean zach why don't you grow some
balls and have this woman killed
truly let's play with this creep this
creep sad with the sweet baby rays
barbecue sauce on the back and i said
that he's this guy he doesn't you know
sweet baby he doesn't know that it goes
on the food he's just trying to like be
a human being but hey zuck why don't you
grow some balls and have this
whistleblower [ __ ] whacked have her
killed
have this [ __ ] killed she's [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up
so this is a stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and have her killed
act like a [ __ ] boss
why don't you ever act like a boss you
always go into congress and you're
always [ __ ]
pale and weird and [ __ ] equivocating
get this [ __ ] stomped out american
history x style make her bite the curb
remember that scene bite the curb and
then start with the boot
do it to this [ __ ]
i want you to watch or get killed zuck
like khashoggi was getting tortured and
then mbs watched it again allegedly no
issues with them allegedly he was
watching it i want zuckerberg to watch
this when we get killed let's see what
he has to say i'm on his side here a
little bit so this is the rebrand with
uh meta so this is the sneak peek at the
facebook metaverse now
meta
is gonna be a better place to sell the
maids
is that what we're
because you're creating a world where
maids will be sold
seamlessly
okay here we go i need a maid
are you coming yeah just gotta find
something to wear
all right perfect
oh hey mark hey what's going on
what's up
that big creature is the maid
they don't show the real maid because
she's bruised and bloody
so what zuckerberg has done
is he has an avatar for his maid
so that it disguises the substantial
physical damage he's done to her
continue this is brilliant i respect
this guy and for anyone confused this is
through vr goggles through like you know
right because if you were to look at it
in actuality you would just see a
bleeding filipino maid
uh-huh who made this place that's
awesome who made this place the next
crater i met in l.a what happened to the
place it is
amazing this is cool this is like vr of
course it's me hey you know i had this
is there a man wasn't there
i hear knocking in the
in a uh garage what happened to the man
you were bluffing
i don't know i think she got sick
the maid got sick let's call her she's
not around anymore stop asking questions
about the [ __ ] maid hey should we
deal you in sorry i'm running late but
you've got to see what we're checking
out there's an artist going around soho
hiding ar pieces for people to find wow
3d street there's some there's people in
the philippines going around hiding
maids
are you guys up on that or no
were you just concerned about the
augmented reality
how about the actual reality we're made
to get beaten back
this is like after 9 11 when they're
like the cia doesn't understand arabic
i'm like no they understand it fine when
they plan the attack
they're like well they they the c.i.a
didn't know anything about the attackers
they don't speak arabic i said i think
they spoke it well when they were
training the hijackers in [ __ ]
arizona
anyway in florida contact us for brand
deals
but
do you see what i mean here and i want
to end with brian laundry being alive
because he is alive brian laundry is
being hit by his parents
canal who opened for me showed me this
video
of brian laundry uh being uh the parents
have a flower bed in the backyard and
you see this video i urge everyone to
look at it under the flower bed there's
some weird
thing that happens where you see a hand
kind of go up i think she's passing him
a note
here's what happened see look at this
bizarre viral conspiracy theory claims
brian laundry is hiding under
parents flower bed
the bizarre conspiracy theory says
jeffrey epstein has an island bizarre
conspiracy there now here's the deal is
this gonna be my sandy hook the laundry
thing where i have to come back probably
but i'm still sticking to this brian
laundry is alive because they only found
his teeth it's very easy to get
somebody's teeth out of their mouth i
don't know that they've made a positive
idea in any of the other bones and the
parents were in the park looking for him
and the said to meet the cops there
they're like meet us there and that was
the day they found him
very strange
can you show the actual video banner not
some [ __ ] newsweek yeah i just
clicked on the link it's a dead link
hold on
get me try this the video up where you
can literally see
something going on
there's a flower bed
they're around it
and then all of a sudden you see
something you see a hand if you close up
on the video you see hand
something is coming out from the side of
the flower bed
and it looks like a hand you can see it
right there
see it there again
go back
watch it again
you see something coming out
she looks like she's doing something
and then all of a sudden
you see a hand come up
like she's doing something and you see a
hand come up something is coming up over
there that's strange
brian laundry is alive i'm calling it
right now
should that be our first versus game
is brian laundry live
that website versus the app
where you can predict
uh things that are gonna happen and i
make really good predictions
so we're gonna start doing stuff with
them but maybe that should be one of our
first games is bryant like when does
brian laundry get found
because i believe that brian laundry is
alive and you know why his parents are
from long island
when he came home and he's like i choked
that [ __ ] out his parents were like i
told you she was no good
you're my beautiful baby his mother said
as he stood there and confessed to
killing his girlfriend you're my
beautiful baby
that [ __ ] was no good said his father
and they're like get under the flower
pot we'll drug you up take a few of your
teeth this will be done in no time he's
alive
brian laundry
is alive
we are going to the uk and we're very
excited about it we are really going
we're not [ __ ] around we're
announcing these dates in the uk
um it's it's been a dream of mine
uh to do comedy in the uk i've already
done it but it's another dream and i'm
doing it again
i've done it in scotland but we're going
now to london we're going to ireland
we're going to scotland it's going to be
big
big baby
january 13th we're in dublin
january 15th we're in london
january
15th we're in london
january 16th we're in london
do you get it
15th and 16th we're in london
the 13th were in dublin
no scotland huh
apparently i wanted to do scotland we're
gonna do scotland soon where can they go
get tickets okay so uh the links uh we
will have them on monday uh november 1st
at 9 a.m local time tim's artist
pre-sale will start on tuesday 11 2 at 9
a.m we will pump this on social media
there's a lot of people that want to
come out to the uk we're excited to be
there we want to eat some of their
horrible food
the only thing good there is indian food
and obviously if you spend a lot of
money to go to michelin star restaurant
you can get good stuff but i mean the uh
everything else is just dog food the
english roast is atrocious
maybe change my mind
as steven crowder would say
english rose sucks changed my mind
uh it's an overcooked piece of meat
where yorkshire pudding and tasteless
gravy and mushy peas but maybe i'm wrong
maybe i'll go out and have an uh amazing
one but the
the food in england is quite literally
for the birds
but
we hope that doesn't influence your uh
buying of tickets we're gonna have a
good time uh we're back on the road
we're in indianapolis on the third
indiana there are
tickets left on wednesday we have two
shows in pittsburgh we've added a second
show
okay carnegie music hall sold out our
second show is going to be there
really really great and then washington
dc one of my favorite places to do
comedy there are some tickets left on
saturday so that's our little run for
the next week and then we've got of
course a ton of other dates on the
website but we have indianapolis
morgantown west virginia can't forget
that so indianapolis on the third
morgantown west virginia on the fourth
then two shows in pittsburgh on friday
finally saturday in washington dc
opening for me the great sam talent
hosting the show cool mom
we're bailing her out
cool
mommy
hey man i don't know what to say i it's
hard to make moral judgments but
sometimes they need to happen
you should never be facilitating sexual
assault um and she seems to have a
little weird relationship with the kids
where she's snapchatting the kids and
but you know i do i do recognize the
value of this human being the wild
mother
the mother who doesn't accept that she's
old who wants to get [ __ ] up with the
kids this isn't important you need these
train wrecks
in your life to teach you what you don't
want to be but also allow you to drink
and use drugs you should go from loving
these parents to thinking oh this is a
little sad
first year of college you start looking
back and going yeah it's a little sad
but when you still have fun with them
you still drink with them because it's
kind of all they have
um but you need those people those
parents are essential
when you grow up you didn't have any of
that you didn't have any of this no it's
this is essential if you're a human you
know
you know it is essential to have these
kind of uh you know somebody's mother's
got to be a basket case
right
someone's mother's got to be a basket
case who's unwilling to admit that she's
old and she wants to hang out and party
and get [ __ ] up
and teach you that life can be fun life
can be fun breaking the rules can be fun
drinking when you shouldn't
getting [ __ ] up
in a big ass house
and getting your dick wet now
consensually
so i don't know what what uh cool mom
was doing but
i'm happy to have her on the tour stay
away from mark zuckerberg and facebook
you know what they're doing over there
they're selling maids
that's what the whole site is now
a bunch of maids for sale let's see by
the way if this worked
oh the facebook post
yeah ben thanks for paying attention
uh
notifications
70 likes
and comments and nobody
is
no it's not down
so mark zuckerberg i have does anyone
want a maid i have one chain of in my
basement she will work you can hit her
and you did that 20 minutes ago that's
enough time to make a transaction
i've already i've already sold my maid
i don't
i don't need to have it up anymore
the buyer has already come to my house
and walked out of it with a chained-up
maid
hey thanks facebook
this is what i mean about the social
media
mark
zuckerberg is facilitating
the beatings of maids
and cool mom was just trying to have a
little fun in the burbs
and yet one of them's a billionaire and
one of them's in jail is that okay
well i think not all the while brian
laundry is alive living very comfortably
under a flower bed with his long island
degenerate parents in florida i'm the
only one who's bringing this up because
the new york times is writing about
[ __ ] millennials that are scared of
nihilus gen z cretins well how about
ditching the office anyway go and do
your own goddamn thing you don't need
[ __ ] human resources you don't need
corporate retreats get on [ __ ]
facebook and buy and sell a maid
and if you don't do that you're a
[ __ ] chill
you're a cog in the wheel
facebook facilitates the buying and the
selling of human beings chattel
modern day slavery
and there's not a goddamn thing we can
do about it there's nothing we can do
about it
so you better embrace it
you better sell or get sold
if you are not selling a maid on
facebook you're a maid that's going to
get sold
and i bet that's what cool mom said to
the kids
when she locked him in a room and she
told him to [ __ ] each other's brains out
she said you're either a maid getting
sold or you're one doing the selling
what do you think our last words were
when the cops busted in
and they put her in the in the back of
the patty wagon and drove her away
cool mom looked at all those kids and
said listen this is the price of cool
i've seen a lot of people leaving cop
cars some of my friends parents the
price of being cool
is leaving in a cop car
truly
and that's what you probably mouth to
the kids this is the price of being cool
she said let him say anything they want
about me
but i was cool
i let you get [ __ ] up didn't i
i'll let you do whatever you wanted
let him say what they want about me
doesn't matter
because i ain't no maid
and she got in the car
and then they just drive her off into
the metaverse
and now cool mom will arrange
child sex orgies in the metaverse
and all will be right with the world
it'll fix everything
just a bunch of avatars
getting drunk and [ __ ] in a 6 000
square foot home in tahoe
this is the society and world that we've
created and this is the one that we must
endure
goodbye until next week
get your maids get them now
hello
colin quinn tim dillon how are you
hi tim
you're on my podcast and we're very
excited about your new show
well thank you
remember the first time the last first
and last time i was on your podcast
about five or six years ago to do my
other show and i remember distinctly
saying
i'm doing you a favor being on here and
you know it and now
you might say the tables have turned
[Laughter]
that's how the world works well i don't
know about that i'm very excited now
your last show was red state blue state
it was uh i saw it
it was hilarious
where are you going are you going with
the same idea of like you do a brilliant
job at like taking these very big ideas
and making them funny is that what the
new show is can you tell us like about
the new show at all well put it this way
like if you don't like my new show
nobody will it discusses everything
that's going on right now
and in the uh you know and where it's
all leading and what it all means that's
how i feel about it it's funny of course
you know
but i mean that's something that's the
thing people have to remember in comedy
be funny at all times but right yeah
it's it's the same thing only it's
obviously a different situation more
dire you might even say
you both know every one of your projects
is very ambitious like everything you're
like it's everything that's going on
what it all means and where it leads
and most people now do a special on hbo
and they're like what's it about and
they're like my mom's a drunk
[Laughter]
you know like
i was poor it was weird i wore a dress
to a chick-fil-a someone gave me a dirty
look that's what my hour's about
but i'm excited to see this now you're
doing a run in new york city
yeah i'm doing three weeks in new york
and now hopefully i'll be able to sneak
over to the beacon and see your show i
would have i would love that if you can
but i figured that you were probably
busy
doing your show
i'm doing my shows but i've had a couple
of friends
go see you undercover in california and
they said it's brilliant well that's
that's very good of them and hilarious
by the way oh good where did they where
did they go
i think it would winter uh
not irvine what's up ontario out in the
desert yes ontario yeah
i spent half of my set there was a
circus next to me
and i spent half of my set lamenting
that i wasn't booked at the open air
tent circus
next door because i mean when the
world's ending why pretend anymore let's
just get in the real tent
um
well that's i'm glad we have our our
your manager and my good friend brian
will be coming so you let us know
there'll be a ticket for you where can
people kind of grab tickets are there
tickets still available to your run or
are they all sold out
they're selling out quickly just kidding
there's plenty available okay um
yeah now they could just go to
colinquin.com it's really you know
collinquin.com to get tickets it's at
the lucille lortel theater
it's a run from november 2nd to the 20th
what i love about colin is he does a run
you do a run in one theater you get to
know the theater that's what i
really respect about this what you do is
like
you just put on a show it's like that
old tradition of new york theater
that i used to be a part of when i was
nine years old where you would do a run
for three to four weeks
in one theater in the village in like a
black box theater and uh that's my out
of town run yeah and are you touring it
afterwards after new york
people you said that you know the
out-of-town room was philly in those
days right right i reversed it i make
the out of town run new york
i'll do it yeah i'm gonna go you know
i'm gonna go hit all
all the usual suspects we're talking
about the
bethlehem we're talking about you know
all those places you know those uh
you know those former
formerly once great
uh you know lake erie type places yeah
it's where comedy thrives where comedy
thrives if there's a mobile morgue
comedy's doing well
yeah when men built once built this
country that's true
we i we call them birthing persons now
we're birthing persons yeah my brother
first built this country let's build
this country no those those old places
are are great to do stand up and it's
great i just got back from portland in
seattle and yes it's a hotbed of uh
anarchy and crime but there's something
brilliant about just the gray
rainy
heroin addicted atmosphere the the the
crowds are really great because they
really want to laugh
but it also probably
genetically reminds you of the our old
country that's right that's right
you ever see train spotting we should do
an american train spotting yeah that is
right that's a good point have you been
back i'm going to dublin to perform in
january have you been back there
recently
the last time i was there was three
years ago
and it was amazing i mean and you know
mark norman made the observation about
the crowds he goes these cuz they're
drinking the whole time yes and he goes
because these crowds are drinking the
whole time even we're doing like 9 30 10
o'clock shout out to you but they
they are not easy they you live and die
off every joke yes they they want to
hear exactly what you're saying next and
they're not there
there's no momentum with the irish
people where you're like hey well you
know as you know
just from life right there's no hey hey
we're gonna give you free pass because
the last one could it's like no what's
this one now you know
but they were great it's a constant
reassessment
of what's going on at any moment but i'm
excited to get over there and hopefully
they you know they enjoy it and uh
i just like a nice sad place to do
comedy you know
yes i agree with you and i wasn't on
stage at the hollywood improv the other
night it was a fun show but you look it
out the audience you go we don't need to
be doing this
no no you're right yeah we like blink
bleep toss is funny yes that's good
everyone
colinquin.com this is where you're going
to get tickets to lucille lortel theater
the run is november
2nd through the 20th and and colin i
hope i mean we're on the 11th but i hope
you can get over there i mean you might
not be able to
what time has it been
uh seven yeah yeah 7 p.m you're probably
getting it
you have a show on the 11th i know i
know it's all right around town someone
made it somewhere else yeah we'll figure
it out
we'll figure it out my friend all right
well listen thank you for calling
everybody if you like comedy go see this
show
thanks all right brother talk soon see
you colin